I've just watched a video of a YouTuber
loses absolute freaking mind over the
new Starfield game
and I have to ask
has the world completely lost its mind
welcome to side track your Sci-Fi TV and
muja
[Music]
so this guy
slamming his headphones down absolutely
losing his mind over the fact then the
new role-playing game by Bethesda called
Starfield you can pick what pronoun you
want to be described as in the game when
you're setting up your avatar
apparently a big part of this game is
that the Avatar can almost be unique to
you that there's loads and loads of
different options so you can create an
avatar that is representative of you
now Bethesda two years ago announced
that they were going to do this and I
believe there's a couple of other games
they've done as well but when Starfield
has come out
YouTubers like this idiot I saw today
idiot that's his pronoun
um and others have got very upset and
have even demanded their money back over
this thing over this option and that's
why I remember it's an option
they've been arguing that this
bethesda's forcing their Politics on me
I just want to play a game that's
immersive I just want to immerse myself
in the computer game I don't want your
politics on me
it's an option it doesn't it's you just
put in here and move on surely
now I'll I'll admit I'm quite liberal I
generally believe that people should be
able to live the way they want to live
and I remember that when things are done
they're not done just for me
so that actually you know TV shows
movies all these sorts of things they're
made for a wider audience and we have to
have some inclusion
um I do think there's an issue when they
sort of have a movie about Richard III
setting the you know whatever yeah
Richard the third is about and they
start having black characters and things
because of inclusionism and I'm like
well no because that's history that's a
bit different but generally speaking
you know movies TV they should be
inclusive
just common sense for me because the
world is inclusive so
but
this guy is getting so upset and a lot
of these people are getting so upset
because of this
issue and I would just argue that the
game is made for everyone so that
somebody that is
transgender or does identify as he she
they whatever can still play the game
the whole point is that this option
again a very small part of lots of other
things
is there so that if that's important to
you you have that option and if it's not
important to you ignore it
this really is
the stupidest thing I think I could be
doing a video on today which is why I've
just done it like this really quickly
I'm not going to edit this video I'm
just going to throw it on because it's
so idiotic I can't believe I feel like I
need to mention it
but I've just seen another video now
going on very shortly that star feels
gone woke and people are going to be
talking about this
a war in the Ukraine right now
tens of thousands of people are dying we
have
climate change we have
a
homeless epidemic in this country at the
moment we have Bloody covert apparently
coming back
and you know we have bigger fish to fry
than this
and actually
people that identify as trans and a gay
or whatever they don't need this crap
you know so
it's just I think when you if you're
getting angry about something like this
it says a lot more about you than it
says about woke or anything else
and if you're a YouTuber that your
business is gaming
you should have known about this two
years ago so why are you getting so
upset about it so I would actually
question how serious you take your job
idiot
the world has got way bigger problems
than this
on woke I just try to watch The Wheel of
Time by the way I watched 20 minutes of
it turned it off put Stargate the latest
on instead God that I don't get I
know people have said it's work whatever
else it's not just what it's just not
very good so
just as an added to this little ranty
video
don't bother with others crap season two
came out so I thought I'd sit and watch
it not for me
but anyway
Starfield a role-playing game
for the love of God people calm down
thanks very much stay safe see you next
time
[Music]